The 5G wireless transformation requires
the right frequencies. Now, low-band radio
spectrum transmits small amounts of data
over long distances. The high-band transmits
large amount of data over short distances.
Now, the mid-band spectrum — or so-called
"Goldilocks" frequencies, such as
the C-band — they have the right combination of
both properties, but it's in short supply.
Now, 5G will allow wireless services to
carry more data faster. Using the C-band
is the fastest way to make 5G available
in as many places as possible.
It's essential for US leadership to harmonize
devices with global 5G standards.
Now, satellite operators have this C-band
spectrum and are willing to sell it
so it can be repurposed for 5G. But
seizing this opportunity depends upon
the FCC — the Federal Communications Commission.
It has to move quickly to hold a public auction in 2020.
If the FCC fails to act or moves too slowly,
the US will lose the 5G race to China.
5G innovation, investment, and jobs will go elsewhere.
Should the US be the global leader in 5G
technologies? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.